beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hey everybody Welcome to the Hogwarts
Legacy gameplay showcase I'm Chandler
Wood Community manager here at Avalanche
software and I'm honored to introduce
you to our panel today first up we have
Community guest host Ben snow oh my God
I can't believe this is happening thank
you so much for having me and from the
Avalanche team we have game director
Alan two hello everybody and systems
designer McKenzie toner hi and finally
just off-screen capturing gameplay for
us Andrew Coram
foreign
today we'll be giving you a taste of the
open world via broom flight a deeper
look at combat using the dark arts
battle arena and a look at your
personalizable home within Hogwarts the
room of requirement where we may even
see some beasts
and we're starting right where we left
off in our last gameplay showcase just
outside Hogwarts which I I love that we
can you can walk out of the castle after
walking through everything and then just
come out here and take off on your broom
out into the open world and Alan I know
that's something that you particularly
like about Hogwarts Legacy too yeah I'm
I'm uh I'm a big fan of just being able
to hop on the broom and go anywhere
there's something about kind of like the
the sensation of of everything being
open to you and just I love the
proximity that I can get to things I
love flying close to the ground and and
I I kind of wanted to talk about it just
because I feel like
um you know the brooms are fun for me
not just because of all those feelings
of exhilaration but but because they're
not just I have a broom and it's done I
actually kind of like some of the
mechanics in it so you can you see in
the lower right there's a meter there
and and occasionally as Andrew's kind of
flying up or flying down you might
notice it in draining or not and and
this isn't the present day where all the
broom technology is well known and
advanced and and everything that we know
and love this is an earlier time where
they're still trying to figure out you
know we're not at the 3000 yet we're
like we're at the 11. so I just I'm just
so speechless right now because this is
just so beautiful the world just looks
so by the way the the broom is like the
only one or can you like operate the
rooms the whole Busters yeah so we have
uh stop in Hog's meat actually a broom
shop and so that sells a variety of
different brooms and it was important to
us that the player could customize
themselves based on their own Aesthetics
so they're purely cosmetic but uh if you
talk to the shopkeep and help him out
he'll actually sell upgrades
and those those upgrades will make it so
that where normally the broom you can
only fly
um you can only go at Max Speed it's
kind of like a turbo meter down there
you can only go at Max Speed without the
meter going down kind of closer to the
ground and as you raise into the air
you'll notice the meter drop and so
those upgrades will allow you to
increase that distance from the ground
and there the the broom owner at at the
sporting goods store in in hogsmead is
trying to perfect the broom and get
better at it and and know it better and
you can participate that and get better
and better brooms through this I see and
I love that that mechanic encourages you
to actually explore the world and kind
of stay close to the ground it's not
just a travel mechanic point A to point
B you're not just flying high over
everything although it is beautiful
something I really love doing but as
well there's lots to lots to explore on
the ground and so kind of keeping you
down at the ground level to me it feels
like it's got this kind of Surfing Vibe
over the oh really good like I'm just
like I want to snatch the controller
from Andrew right now because I want to
go to the Mountaintop I'm going to the
forest enter that Hamlet
we're gonna we're actually gonna land
here and I I feel like I feel like that
you call it a hamlet is is just perfect
just because that's what we refer to
that is and so uh we all know for more
that hogsmeade is the only all Wizarding
village within Britain but we wanted
other opportunities to kind of meet
other characters out here and to kind of
populate the landscape so it's not just
kind of you know Barren as you leave out
this direction in that direction and so
we just imagine these different
dwellings these different smaller
locations that that Wizards might live
in out in the Scottish Highlands and so
it's those uh and so we refer to those
as hamlets and their opportunities to
learn those wizard stories
um how those different locations have
kind of like learned to live what their
relationships are with characters that
Hogs me from Hogwarts and so they're
both Quest opportunities out here and a
chance to kind of get to know more of
the area even Beyond Hogwarts and
hogsmead that we've already experienced
and you'll also notice on the mini map
like lots of little icons and each one
of those represent gameplay in in the
hamlets that you can participate in you
know whether it's a vendor or different
puzzles and challenges or different
secrets that exist each one of those
icons are different opportunities for
gameplay and you'll notice that that
same thing as we venture out into the
open world as well so when you go into
the open world and you see see those
icons whether they're on the mini map or
on your map or off in the distance those
things are opportunities to say like I
want to increase my inventory capacity
their puzzles left behind by old Wizards
you know that you can solve that
actually Grant you those if you see
ruins off in the off in the distance and
you visit them you might find
Opportunities to actually expand and
learn about your ancient magic and as
you and as you kind of encounter
different enemies dotted on the
landscape sometimes those characters
poachers or dark Wizards might be
hoarding different uh magical resources
that are valuable to you as you're
playing the game so each one has kind of
like a way to connect to our gameplay
loops and provide different
opportunities that just kind of reward
you for poking around them and mean I
right away when I want to just cover all
of those points on the map just been
going over there but we've flown on a
broom already but there is something
that we haven't done so far and that is
uh getting on our flying Mount we're
gonna hop on our Onyx hippogriff here
the Onyx hippogriff is our pre-order
bonus oh wait I think he just like tops
out of the
the back oh wait
horsey I mean of course yeah
um as a hippogriff you can you can
totally write it like a ground Mount and
you can lift off into the air and we
tried to make sure that each each of
those interactions so the broom's really
good at reaching that top speed at kind
of traveling the world as quickly as
possible but sometimes it's really nice
to get on the hippogriff because of that
ground speed or those Transitions and
sometimes it just feels amazing just to
be riding around on it
yeah it's it really is kind of like uh I
don't know it's a great feeling being on
it and it's a great feeling managing
those transitions kind of going from run
to fly and just being able to go
wherever you want and we tried to make
sure that that though that each one of
these things that you can interact with
have have a unique identity and a reason
for being
and oh my God like I see like different
like areas like a swampy area by the way
can you go to like entire map anywhere
you go there are regions that are like
locked from you yeah as soon as as soon
as you there's kind of a moment where
the World kind of opens up to you
outside of Hogwarts as a student and
right from that moment early on in the
game you can go wherever you want and so
you might find more difficult challenges
in different areas and you'll see
different spots as Andrew's moving
around like you mentioned the swamp but
there we have got like a coast and we've
got different types of environments out
in the world just to kind of pepper your
experience reward you for exploring keep
things fresh all those things exist as
we're moving around I love that windmill
it's like so rustic like I keep
forgetting that this is like 1800s The
Wizard World we've never really sing
before like it feels so authentic like
it just it's part of it yeah I love this
Vista too and and I'm going to have
Andrew stop here we're gonna use a bit
of Dev magic to change the seasons
actually I want to see I want you to see
what this world looks like uh covered in
snow yes yes please I love snow baby
oh
my god oh this is so beautiful oh my
goodness
this is so pretty okay it was so
realistic
oh my God it changes the landscape like
completely oh my God does it have like
actual like gameplay impact like an
impact on the gameplay or does it like
it's just the weather of Scotland uh
yeah we use it we really use it as a
narrative marker through through the
game so as you're progressing through
your main storyline it was important for
us to kind of like have those moments
that kind of felt like when you're
reading the books or watching the movies
where you know you'll see kind of like
the title card winter and now the
landscape has changed and you're really
feeling those that passage of time while
you're a student you know going through
your year at Hogwarts and I think I
think we wanted to duplicate that and
for me it's really fun that it's not
just on the outside which which I I
agree I think it was really beautiful
um but within the school as well so
there are moments like when it reaches
certain holidays or things like that
where hogsmead
holidays and the school reacts to
holidays and you see the decorations
around those environments change that
really helped just kind of make me feel
like I'm there right and and it's not
just uh it's not just you know for the
seasons those those kind of vibe things
um like we have a day night cycle and
that day night cycle it even though
similarly like it's largely about Vibe
when you go into hogsmeade in the
evening there's less characters there
around the school you'll notice it kind
of dies down and quiets down just I mean
there's just Candlelight and students
kind of like as you're walking through
the Halls but in that day night cycle is
where we've kind of placed a few items
where you know whether or not you can
collect them or whether or not you can
interact with them with that are a
little bit restricted by the day night
cycle
and I love Andrews flying up here really
high up on the hippogriff and and we're
just looking at this view of Hogwarts in
the distance it's just absolutely
beautiful it's part of what I love most
about flying around in this game whether
it's on a hippogriff or or on the Broom
no I I mean you talk about going
anywhere and things that you can see in
the distance and that's one of my I I
still can't get over like no matter I
play this so much but I still I still
can't get over the fact that I can see
Hogwarts out there and there's just
something beautiful about knowing that
all of all of the things inside of it
the classrooms the students the
professors all the places I can go I can
just fly my hippogriff land in the
courtyard enter the front doors and just
walk you know to the library to class or
two Greenhouse or to my common room that
it's all contiguous and just kind of
like one one space is still exciting to
me after all this I mean I'm just just
I'm speechless right now it's just
absolutely beautiful it's just as much
as we want to spend a lot more time out
here just flying around experiencing the
world
I think this is a great opportunity to
switch over to combat and last time we
gave you kind of an intro to combat this
time we're going to really go a lot more
of a deep dive on using the dark arts
battle arena which is part of our deluxe
edition
all right Andrew's got us in the
Forbidden Forest which is where the dark
arts battle arena is uh which is part of
the deluxe and digital deluxe edition I
I love the way that the dark arts battle
arena is actually uh part of the world
that's integrated into the world so your
experience is more immersive than just
choosing an option from from the main
menu of the game or something like that
exactly there are many reasons to go to
the Forbidden Forest but uh he's also
wearing the uh dark arts cosmetic set
and uh here he's pulling out the
thestral which is oh my God part of that
dark arts pack from the deluxe and
digital deluxe edition so we're going
full full dark arts here
um that's good that's what I'm going
down but I like this uh this battle
arena it is a great place to show off
um really combat in a big way because it
unlocks some interesting abilities for
you and allows you to really play around
with combat in a deep way and is this
like the only Arena like this in the
game where you can like practice it yeah
so in the in the base game we have two
combat Arenas normally that and so
everyone has access to those and each of
the combinator units are an opportunity
to kind of just go through a difficult
combat Challenge fight through multiple
waves in order to earn a a different
cosmetic for your character and add that
to your collection in the case of the
that's no different than the dark arts
battle arena that's also true of the
combat Arena but uh but uh one of the
things that we're excited about in the
dark arts battle arena that people can
do is is you come in pre-loaded with
different abilities so the unforgivable
curses are something that everyone's
going to have access to through the base
game and going to be able to earn and
they can make choices in order to kind
of like add that to the repertoire and
they can also commit to that down with
certain talents and things like that
when you when you play the Dark Horse
combat Arena you actually have access to
all those things as kind of like a way
to test them all and so it's a chance to
kind of like tour and play with the dark
arts and decide whether or not that is a
path that you kind of want to go down
but but yeah everyone has the same
ability to explore explore the dark arts
this is just kind of like a way of
previewing and again a great place for
us to show off combat in general so I
think we're gonna jump in here Andrew's
gonna start just start battling and we
can start talking about everything
you're seeing on the screen all right
away oh my God we're starting off strong
is that was that Cujo oh my God that's
so cool yeah so that you'll you'll
notice right away like when we use Avada
cadaver that guy's how far went from
instant to zero and we really are trying
to honor the way Avada cadaver works in
the game even in some pretty extreme
situations
um you'll notice that like the the meter
takes up a lot longer to yeah build up
as a way to kind of deal with its
extreme power just that it's still fun
to use and then there's some some ways
that we'll probably talk about to to to
adjust that but I don't know I I don't
know if there are things on the screen
that you just have questions about well
like I see like little blue things
from the enemies also before like that
sign well it's like so in the community
we call it the ancient magic sign I
don't know if that's how it's called
yeah in the game so the community is
asleep so on the development side and
player facing in the game we reference
that as your ancient magic
it is ancient magic that is yeah so as
your as your abilities in the game keep
growing and you become exposed to some
of the secrets about your own kind of
history and your own your own abilities
um you start unlocking new powers so one
of those Powers you'll see the R1 button
appearing uh throughout the game uh
that's an ancient magic throw we call it
that allows you to kind of like draw an
object to you and fling it at an enemy
um okay but whenever you see the R1 or
the L1 plus R1 up here over somebody's
head that's an ability to cast a very
devastating and Powerful ancient magic
spell to do a ton of damage against the
characters and the way that manifests
itself uh depends on the type of enemy
that you're fighting and you'll see a
wide variety of enemies in here that are
pressuring the player in different ways
you'll notice there's there's uh
abilities that kind of bubble up under
the player as it's fighting that forcing
to move and there's different ways that
we want the player to kind of move
around on the battlefield and that's
actually a good link to the intermagic
leader in general and the reason why I
say that is because as you're doing
different things in combat you're
protegoing and you're doing different
abilities and kind of spectrum through
your talents there are different ways to
get that meter to build faster and
faster but one of the most effective
base ways to build up that meter fast
that way you can launch these
devastating attacks whenever you want to
is is to actually perform combos so you
see that combo it's almost like your
your emotions are building up and then
basically that built up enough that you
can attack someone but as the combo
meter builds up at some point you strike
someone and a piece of their magic kind
of falls out of them you'll see these
blue orbs in in the in the game world
and there's something that only you can
see in in the narrative in the world and
it's another reason to move around on
the battlefield if you can build up and
collect those things and suck them in
they give big big jumps to that ancient
magic meter as we're playing we're
talking a lot about about spells and
Magic here but I think there's another
huge component of combat and that is the
the tools that you can bring to combat
as well to kind of uh change the way you
play and I think Mackenzie knows a lot
about what's going on with the plants
and potions and so the the tools are
really interesting because they're
basically like a prior investment so you
can bring the potions and the plants
that you grow in the room of requirement
to combat to essentially kind of help
you defeat enemies a lot quicker and
more efficiently so some of the tools
that you'll see here are like the rock
Skin Potion so that is something that
basically covers your skin in this like
Rocky material that
reduces the incoming damage that you're
receiving so against big enemies
hard-hitting enemies like trolls that's
super helpful
um oh my God she's just destroying the
troll just collapsed from whatever
obviously we have the Wicked Wheel
potion as well which increases your
health and then we have the focus lotion
so when Alan talks about having to
balance Avada Kadabra with a long cool
down because obviously it's an instant
fill one thing that you could do is brew
a focus potion and that will increase
how quickly your your cooldowns regain
right
there's just so much like a versatility
like what the character is doing to the
troll right now like he's just bouncing
around around the arena he's like nuts
and the troll makes him move around too
looks like and I love that our plants
are violent yes and so that's like when
we're talking about the almost the setup
of the Arena you also have plants that
you can fight with and so we have things
like the venomous tentacula that you can
put down and it acts like a turret and
it just kind of shoots enemies around
the battlefield that is so cool this is
like a truly like apple puffy and way
too approach the battle yes no that was
super important to us so there were
things like multiple ways and so you can
see there's there's a ton of different
things you can use the Mandrake is one
so you can pull it out and it stuns with
this like piercing cries enemies uh in a
radius another thing I want to call out
uh that we're seeing on the side of the
screen here is these these dueling Feats
which I love because I love anything
that prompts me to play a game in a
different way a unique way I don't want
to get stuck in my style you know uh and
and so this is a way to if you want to
get stuck in your style go for it if you
just want to blast people with spells go
for it but we also want to uh have some
things over here that may make you use
certain plants or certain potions or
block more or yeah we mentioned the
field guide challenges
um uh in the prior stream and the field
guide challenge is this is the way that
the field guide manifests like
challenges for you to do and exactly to
your point
um we just wanted a way to encourage
players to to explore the different
systems to help them decide to just kind
of practice with them and explore what
they want to be because there really are
so many different ways that you can push
talents when you see the the green x's
on characters that's right and that's
kind of uh through your talents you can
unlock this kind of cursing mechanic
that sort of like links the fates of
these different characters on the
battlefield that way uh as you get the
as you're cursing different characters
they all begin sharing damage and so we
have things like Avada kedava which is
the insta-kill but if you curse everyone
before you insta kill this one guy they
can all drop dead for that kind of
ultimate
and so oh my god there are there are
dark ice fantasies there's fantasies
about being more of a defense against
the dark arts character things like that
that Misty step that you see um
occasionally being used on the
battlefield and we can also spec into
potions and plants to make them more
powerful and more efficacious so it's
all about which type of player you feel
like you are and whether or not you want
to play with prep on the fly or with
deliberation and those are all different
options that is so cool because like
it's like I see so much like going on on
the things of so much complexity and I I
want to just try it myself like which
style works best I mean I feel like it's
the Dark Horse is going to be basis
they're ancient magic to be honest feels
like much more powerful than just the
dark Hearts yeah and speaking of plants
and Potions we are going to be putting
the dark arts away put those
unforgivable curses away uh and heading
to the room of requirement which is your
home within Hogwarts a personalizable
space that actually has some utility as
well where you get to brew things and
grow things and uh also care for some
beasts
all right Andrew's got us in the room of
requirement uh wearing we we kind of
went casual mode on the outfit here
wearing a nice jumper
um and and I think that's a good jumping
off point jumping off point uh for uh
the personalization of the space as well
not just your character and and the
visuals of your character but actually
this space is a place that you can make
your own
um yeah it was super important to us
that this space really did feel like
um your reflection as a wizard so you
can change the architecture in here
different themes throughout starkly
different themes to really just Hammer
home that this is this is yours oh my
God what this is beautiful we never
expected that to be oh my God
that's the thing is not only can you
change the architecture here but you can
actually conjure little objects uh into
this space as you can see so you can
there's like statues that you can do and
ornaments and tables and rugs and just a
bunch of little things that really flesh
out the space and bring it to life oh my
goodness because like we we had an idea
that those places where you brew stuff
that's where you can change but you can
do all of this where do you even get
this stuff like there's a furniture
store yeah so we call them conjurations
uh and the conjuration recipes can be
purchased at tomes and Scrolls in
hogsmeade but also as you engage in
different types of gameplay throughout
the world you'll be rewarded with
different objects that's so cool and you
change the color you can change the
color you can change the size of it and
you can place it basically anywhere oh
my God it's so tiny it's like for baby
niffler and I love how the the system
too is designed it's not mechanical it's
immersive and so you get the magical
effect of conjuring it in and you're
you're you're actually doing this in the
world as your character but the way
you've Blended like that gameplay with
the immersive uh design of personalizing
the space god like and I love the
animation how it like appears you know
like it's not just like there it's like
it's almost like it operates it is
really quite beautiful and that was the
thing is we wanted that to look really
nice because the Magic in The Wizarding
World is everywhere it's it's physical
it's kinetic and it's whimsical we
really wanted to nail that Whimsy in
this space another thing that I wanted
to discuss is that not only can you like
conjure things and you can change their
their look but you can do that with the
utility objects as well so you can see
that we have planting pots and potion
stations and you could change the look
of those as well and these are the areas
where as we had mentioned previously
you'll be growing your plants you'll be
brewing your potions right right right
right right
so while you're also doing these uh like
kind of nurturing based activities this
is also the space where you would bring
your gear Gear to be identified and
geared to have um like rates put on it
which I believe Alan can talk to oh yeah
um I we keep bringing up with parents
and and how it looks and and on like uh
in the game you can look like anything
you want to whenever you want to
um but the player will be finding
different types of gear that we call it
uh as you progress through the game and
essentially we just know that that
clothes and different items in The
Wizarding World can have different
magical properties and as you uh as you
explore and as You Adventure as you
defeat enemies you're going to be
finding different pieces of gear that
have different abilities and that can
help you in your journey and are a major
part of you kind of growing as a wizard
and advancing as a wizard and so it's a
huge list and not all the time uh
whenever whenever you get a new piece of
gear you don't necessarily know exactly
what it does and so there's a station
inside of the room of requirement that
you can conjure it's one of the first
things you conjure uh called an
identification station where you can
actually see that that gear that you're
uncertain about and learn what its
abilities are right yeah that's so cool
and then as the space advances even
further and the space will eventually
grow its own rooms and you're going to
get new recipes you know like like
McKenzie's talking about all these
different things keep expanding and as
it expands eventually you're going to
earn what we see here which is called a
loom and when you set up a loom it's an
ability to essentially customize exactly
which magical properties are on your
gear and take any piece of gear and
adjust its properties and to tweak what
it does and I mentioned earlier that
that you can make anything look like
anything the collection of of cus of
appearances we call it or Cosmetics
we've been referring to it right the
stream those types of things you can use
and you you can apply a look to any
other other look so if you get a piece
of gear you put it on you look like that
but you can change it to look like
whatever you want
that's so cool and like you just you can
just put some ability to this sweater
but then you can just swap yeah that
ability yep and the appearances you can
edit whenever you want in the gear
screen the loom is specifically about
applying uh traits and and applying uh
larger upgrades that just kind of grant
you greater statistical advantage or
give you really specific abilities that
blend in nicely with where you're trying
to go with your combat fantasy or
talents and things like that interesting
I'm just like I've just seen that
they're just like pump skin fur
mooncuffer where does that come from
yeah and so you'll notice that the
ingredients that are used to add traits
and to upgrade your gear are based
around beasts so this is where we get
into the Beast care section which is
inside this vivario on a bigger space on
the inside idea and so you can see here
we have a couple of beasts out we have a
graph horn and a moon calf and a niffler
and a nasal as well quite a variety oh
my God he's just like a big puppy
oh my God they're together
oh he's heading them as well but feeding
them too and so once you do those things
that's when they feel safe enough they
can they'll give you their their magical
ingredients so mooncap for
um niffler fur Etc that can then be used
in your in your gear that is like so
like intuitive because like you know
that makes sense because when you touch
the animals you get some fur leftovers
that's so
my God yeah and we really want to hammer
home the fact that this is like a home
that you're making for them so in the
Overland you can find these Beast ends
and rescue these beasties part of doing
so is brushing them and feeding them
food as well and to build that
relationship with with your beef in
addition to be able to care for beasts
you can actually conjure things in this
space as well uh the house the cottage
yeah right and so we have like a lot of
little ornaments in this area and a lot
of them are purely cosmetic but they
look really cool again it's the
personalization of this space oh my
goodness no this is like I'm gonna spend
eight hours just designing this whole
area to personalize this is like cool
it's like you have this little clay area
like a personalized fish tank so to say
just for the creatures I love it yeah no
totally and there's like a decoration
aspect but there's also we were saying
inside uh as well is there's a utility
utility aspect to it too so as you
progress in the game and you're able to
purchase more conjugations you're able
to speed up your process so one of them
for example is the food processor which
allows for the beast in the space to
automatically get feed so you don't have
to do it manually and so you're really
building the progression for yourself
here in addition there's also a toy box
where you can play with your beasts
you'll see here yeah so you can there's
a bunch of toys in it and each Beast has
their own favorite toys so as you can
imagine the moon calf really likes the
moon ball or the needle as like a little
cat really likes to chase the yarn ball
and they're super cute
oh my God watching them it's so cute
and the big thing we really wanted to
hammer home uh is that the world is a
dangerous place and so by going and
rescuing these beasts and bringing them
back here and caring for them you're
really helping helping them out there's
poachers in the Overland uh who want to
who hunt these Beasts for their material
so instead you're caring for them you're
giving them a home right oh my God
is just gigantic
but he looks like my dog
oh
you could actually name them as well so
like your dog
so getting back into that
personalization you know yeah we didn't
want you to just like throw in oh here's
a here's a graph horn in here like this
can be named whatever Andrew's about to
name them
Bruce
and uh you you can get additional
vivariums correct uh it's a different
kind of
Aesthetics and looks to where you're
keeping your beast and caring for them
percussion is a big part of the space as
well so as you progress through the
story you will unlock more of a varium
so as you can see this one's quite
Meadow themed
um big open bright but there's other
ones say like a swamp that you might
encounter and it's really a visual
effect to uh and more space for for your
feet oh so it's like those when we're
inside the room requirement there's like
on the left there's that moon glow from
one entrance and then some Shrubbery
going on in the right is that what
you're talking about that's exactly it
oh you put trees in here too oh my
goodness
and and another thing with the the Beast
care that I think is is great uh you
know tying back to this same kind of
thing that you did with like the broom
where the broom is not just a method of
travel it's it's actually built in and
integrated into the world in the same
way like Beast care isn't just this this
added element you're not just throwing
it on top there's really this like
narrative and integration to
yeah everything everything so as you
progress through the missions you'll
expand the space
um as you earn resources you'll go into
hogsmeade and and use them to uh unlock
the gameplay here and unlock new
conjurations and different things to
play around with in the open world uh
it's in those different
um in those different environments like
the different combat and conflicts and
Bandit camps and different things like
that that exist in the Overland those
things are what hold recipes that exist
in the loom so all these things have a
way of connecting
um Moonstone that you find out in the
world is the resource that we use to
conjure everything that's found
throughout the world
forgeables are used for recipes so
really everything's like a everything's
like a cycle and keeps you coming back
but even with the story that's being
told too you know I think people know
who poppy is and and uh that she has a
particular affinity for beasts yeah I
mean I think everything we're seeing
here you know you're going to be
venturing out into the world uh and and
this is just kind of the tip of the
iceberg or even even of kind of like
your interactions with beasts and that
narrative so you know you're bringing up
poppy they're more they're more uh kind
of mysteries to discover and things to
discover around the world that have to
do with her and that have to do with
caring for beasts and so different
characters have their own have their own
stuff uh uh that that just kind of make
this all just kind of the beginning the
beginning of your journey
well we could spend hours in here but
we're gonna have to end the stream now
what do you think about what you've seen
today I mean this is I'm just so blown
away by how
how beautiful it looks the open world
seems so detailed and there's so many
things to do and like the combat we're
gonna have we're gonna spend like two
weeks or more just breaking it down by
pieces there's just so much
to this world like I'm so happy you guys
did this overall gameplay and that's
just the tip of the iceberg we've got
more for you to discover and find on
your own thank you for so much for being
here thank you for watching Hogwarts
Legacy is available for pre-order now it
releases February 10th with 72-hour
Early Access for owners of the
collectors Deluxe and digital deluxe
edition we're gonna wrap things up but
first we've got a little surprise for
you
bye
[Music]
[Music]